THIRSTY JANUARY TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE READ ADVISER AUDIO
OR VIDEO RECORDING TODAY FOR
SUSAN IS BEING MADE AND IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES. THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING
. VIOLATIONS THE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
REFER SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM.
BENNETT BONTA FLORA GIPSON LEE
HERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS
RUBIO. THE MCCORMICK WE HAVE A
QUORUM- WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA. MOVERS TO MASSES OF. THE
HAVE SECONDED ARE. ALEX ARE.
RESERVIST CALL THE ROLL COOLEY I
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. BENNETT BENNETT HI BONTA.
BONTA HIGH FLOOR GIPSON LEE ACT
MAY I MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS I
RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO RUBIO IV
APPROVED BY. HI MISSION PASS TO
MOTIONS PASS AND THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.